eddie murphy when he hosted saturday
night live he said to you i want you to
write me
the gumby sketch that's got to be
[ __ ] intimidating because gumby
always
killed i mean that's a heavy
responsibility that was
one of many very very heavy
responsibilities i mean first of all
it's eddie murphy
so and he's coming back to snl so i
can't go
back home if that show's bad you know
like literally my family would be
more mad at me than eddie would be you
know
you ruined eddie murphy on saturday
night live
yeah and uh yeah it was it was crazy
it was like first of all he comes in and
they
want me to work on the monologue in a
sense you almost want to go
i can't write a monologue for eddie
murphy
you can't you suggest a monologue you
don't write a monologue
you suggested i'm curious about the
process
does he give you any kind of guidance or
do you just sit there and pitch him
jokes
i just wrote it and he you know and then
he just
picked what he liked and we changed some
stuff throughout the week but initially
i just had to like
write it i didn't i didn't know what to
write because we had to add the thing
was we it wasn't just
his jokes we had to add in dave
and chris and tracy and keenan so
there was moving parts and it was the
same thing with with gumby when when he
called me in he was like i want to do a
gumby and say michael che you black
bastard and i was like
it was like on a friday too so i'm
already working on like four
things that i'm like i'm gonna get
killed if any one of these things is bad
and then he was like you black bastard
michael jane i was like
all right so i wrote that up hey don't
you try to make me out to be a racist
che you're black bastard
it was his idea that he wanted to say
michael che you black bastard that's
that's all he gave me that's all he gave
you guys other than that you have to
fill in the blanks
when as a writer you see eddie murphy
performing on stage words that came to
you
in your brain you know that you were
sitting at home it's not real
it doesn't it's baffling it was like
look
so literally that day i was uh that
saturday because
everybody's in the studio everybody
wants to come to this show this before
covet so it's just packed with just
it's the blackest snows i've ever looked
into in my life like
kanye's like it was like crazy and um
yeah we're like just trying to get and i
know everybody and everybody wants to
ask me questions
what's it like what's it i'm like i'm
working like right now
and i remember trying to just go in my
dressing room just to like take like a
10 minute
just like a break and i opened the door
and chappelle
and chris rock are eating sushi in my
dressing room
and they're like hey man how's things
going i'm like what are you doing in
there
it was crazy it was crazy chris called
his mom
from my dressing room to be like mom i'm
i'm at the eddie murphy show i'm not
saying i love eddie murphy's here like
it was like that kind of special for
everybody
and you pinch yourself because these are
your comedy heroes i saw eddie murphy
and dave chappelle host snl
and it like i feel like
i don't know how you top that